Fox News Alert Michael Cohen learns his
fate a federal judge sentencing
president Trump's former personal lawyer
to three years in prison after pleading
guilty to numerous charges including
lying to Congress and violating campaign
finance law let's go to Rick Leventhal
who was inside the courtroom earlier
what you got record and Jesse it was
packed with members of the media also
attorneys and federal agents and three
rows of Michael Cohen's family and
friends who all listened intently as he
spoke for almost 10 minutes before he
was sentenced near the very beginning he
told the judge this may be hard to
believe but today is one of the most
meaningful days of my life
the day I got my freedom back because he
says his blind loyalty to Donald Trump
led him to choose a path of darkness
over light ignoring his own moral
compass and spending several years and
what he called mental incarceration the
hearing lasted just over an hour
included Cohen's attorney asking for
leniency suggesting his client made a
remarkable life decision to cooperate
with the federal government offering
evidence against the most powerful
person in the country saying Cohen was a
man of integrity and an honest
businessman but US attorneys painted a
different picture of a man fueled by
greed and a lust for power who
deliberately and willfully stole
millions and eroded faith in the
electoral process they say trying to
influence the outcome of the
presidential election judge William
Pauley said that somewhere along the way
Michael Cohen did lose his moral compass
and the magnitude and breadth of
misconduct requires significant
deterrence that deterrence as you
mentioned thirty six months in federal
prison three years supervised parole one
point three nine million dollars in
restitution to the IRS the forfeiture of
a five hundred thousand dollar loan and
about a hundred thousand dollars in
fines Jesse he can spend the holidays
with his family he will turn himself in
on March 6th Rick thank you very much
president Trump's ready to fight back as
Democrats ramp up impeachment talk Trump
telling Reuters quote it's hard to
impeach somebody who hasn't done
anything wrong and who's created the
greatest economy in the history of our
country I'm not concerned no I think
that the people would revolt if that
happens you know I kind of agree with
them Gregg especially if the impeachment
is on party line
and if it's something really thin not
major collusion or so that you're
telling me Jessie that you agree with
Donald Trump we know we need another
breaking news book by the way yes I
agree
Trump bears responsibility for employing
Cohen that's not against the law to
employ a bad lawyer who did then I might
have done something wrong
Cohen pleading guilty is not the same as
Trump pleading guilty that Cohen may
have broken the law is not the same as
Trump broke the law
the media is addicted addicted
completely to what ifs not what is or
what ours and and they're spending so
much time on that that they can't see
the truth I love this could I talk about
a vanetti though the press conference
condemning Cohen do we need to show it
let's show it yeah Michael Cohen is not
either our hero nor a patriot Michael
Cohen will report to federal prison
exactly one year after we filed the case
on behalf of stormy Daniels Michael
Cohen was sentenced today Donald Trump
is next oh he's the best it's I would
say the pot calling the kettle black but
that might be racist and he just lost
his Ferrari yes great piece in the daily
signal we call HVS I got that once and
it says Trump's lawyer didn't violate
campaign finance laws and neither did
the president it's a very methodical
look at the Federal Election Commission
how they've ruled on cases that like
this before he would know because he was
an appointee to the federal election you
know a lot about h vs h vs we took a lot
to get him confirmed during the bush
administration act i don't even know if
we ever did but he was an active anyway
h vs great guy abs great right so you
have the campaign finance violation and
that's going to be obviously argued and
president Trump saying people in the
streets with pitchforks do you think
he's sending a message right there there
was support no I do not and I think
anyone who ran it's like the what was it
the rammy
the spoon what I ran away with the spoon
I know a few people that have something
about the spoon I think yeah they they
took it too far I think the what he's
saying is like it is his supporters his
base the people who voted for him who
didn't vote for him because of Russia or
for any other reason that they are going
to say like how could you do this we
voted for him he's the legitimate
president the United States we love what
he's doing how dare you say that he's
saying that there he doesn't mean that
they're going to revolt against the
country and like pick up weapons and go
after people that's not what he meant he
just meant that there would be
frustration right and big time I also
feel like on the campaign finance laws
it is murky I've talked to three
different lawyers today everyone has a
different interpretation of it that's
why you have an FEC but remember Michael
Cohen does not just go to jail for three
years because of campaign finance
violate right he admitted guilt to all
sorts of things in terms of the his his
own decision sectional decision his bad
business dealings and that's really why
he's going to jail exactly all right so
one Donald Trump as we've discussed a
long time he can get her along with
Democrats I mean he's not an ideological
guy did the Democrats risk something if
they go in right from January and say in
peach and Peach and Peach and hold the
line instead rack up some bipartisan
compromises with the president in the
new Congress and the Senate and maybe
get some bills passed and then they can
run and say listen I got things done in
Congress well in fact that's what he
said last night to Reuters he said we
can go down two paths here one is
constructive and one is more of this
kind of Investigation stuff but before
we do that let me just clear quickly say
that in fact Bill Clinton had a better
economy than Donald Trump and he was
impeached so we'll see also you know his
approval rating also went up that's
right so I'm just saying I mean but it's
not a case that because these I mean
little the Trump economy really kicks
off right there the same speech in the
second term yeah I see you're looking
forward yes always looking for there
could be two impeachment wait a second
this is the five we got to go the other
way and the second thing to say is you
guys try to separate
Koen from Trump yes but great I believe
that prosecutors say individual one who
we believe to be President Trump
directed mr. :
remember the argument from the president
was there was no payment to stormy
Dana's no we weren't paying anybody and
then the second thing this he said oh no
crime wait you won't even let me finish
but the second thing he did was then he
blames Cohen right he says it and then
he says that lawyer Oh Abed that's right
he said so and then he's you know all of
this kind of denial and lies by the
president you can't ignore the product
in not collusion one who's involved tell
you though this is this is why the
American putt we should do a whole hour
on this do you know what do you know
what Muller's prosecutors said today in
court Owen was helpful to them by
providing information about Trump's
contact with Russia what is not what do
you think yeah I mean I think that so
what you saw with Cohen in both Americas
news media they they pled to this they
did plea deal so this wasn't litigated
and in a court and so I think that if
this does go before the Congress this
isn't settled while this hasn't been
tested in the adversarial Court and I
think the as dana said the president can
make a clearer argument here that i was
doing something to protect my family i
similarly talked to several lawyers
today and had everyone had a different
response on this so it comes down to the
politics what are the 20-30 Republican
senators in the Senate think if the
house and peaches and do they want to
remove a president for what is a
campaign violation or making a payment
to protect his family